are you ready Alex I am are you ready
Christian dough puffs of puppy movies
yes that's right you have to pop them
anyway without using your hands oh yes
yes because they are very very sensitive
oh you remember that time in sports with
girls with girls just so much
personality to it this is pop quiz I'm
the Nostalgia Critic and ever since I
was a child I always want to play games
quoting movies and TV with my friends
the only problem was I had no friends
well now that I have power I can take my
friends by force with the help of my new
pal general anaesthetic
I can kidnap all the friends I want and
force them to answer questions it might
save by the Bell style scent there will
be laughs trivia those disturbing
cartoons that give you night terrors but
most of all there will be fun the
laughter and joy will last however long
I want
heads up America for this is pop quiz
hotshot
[Music]
welcome to pop quiz hotshot I have two
lovely friends with me here today
Christian and Alex yes yes you are very
happy and you are my friends right you
are my friend over here I'm over here
yes yes don't don't blink for help it
doesn't work so there aren't people up
there all home I can't it's the internet
they'll read any codes but they won't
help you because again it's the internet
so I'm gonna start with Alex here Alex
it says that you lived in Romania for
three years and that is true it was very
fun great time
I don't know absolutely nothing about
Romania so just tell me what it is is it
a place it is definitely a place that I
would consider it a place not much of a
place I it was it was a magical time a
magical time that is in not much of a
place yes exactly I stay for the
communism but I left for the democracy I
found my next vacation spot yeah
Cristian I see you with the pony shirt
there and I know there's definitely
people out there they like to make fun
of them and like to make jokes I'm not
gonna do that because I respect the fact
that you like a show that's a
well-written show and it's creative in
everything so I'm totally gonna leave
that alone and still go to the fact that
you write brony fanfiction how can I
leave that alone you have made it
impossible for me to leave that alone
you like ponies
I don't care do I dare ask what kind of
pony fanfiction you're right because I
go on deviantART it scary stuff is that
your fanfiction is just riding over and
over do you like ponies do you like
ponies is that your fanfiction no fan
fictions about characters I create and
interacting with main characters of a
show well that sounds respectable dammit
if I had a lot more material for that
okay well then we're just gonna jump
right into this but we can't until we
know how to play the game general
anaesthetic why don't you tell us each
contestant is asked a series of
questions involving the size of quotes
if the contestant does not know the
answer but can make the nostalgia critic
laugh ten points are still given but
look out for the spasms the first one to
hit their buzzer when they appear ends
the round while the other has to pay the
penalty through round two where the
quotes Kady
harder the winner with the most points
face off against the nostalgia critic
and a one-on-one match
if the contestant wins they walk out
with a cash prize and also their lives
if they lose the cash prize will be
added to the next contestants winning
wonderful are you both ready go write
fanfiction about Christian which movie
contained the line you have part of my
attention you have the minimum amount
the rest of my attention is back at the
offices of Facebook if you can't get
this I am really gonna write some call
any fanfiction about you men they can
joke about that hard-on I thought yes
I'm sure all the ponies have Facebook
Jessica ladies made of for Alex in Who
Framed Roger Rabbit which cartoon
character said I'm not bad I'm just
drawn that way I know the actor but that
doesn't help no no it doesn't funny you
know I'll give you because I'm curious
now I'll give you the point if you can
name the actor he does Doc Brown was one
of the characters you're immediately
wrong cuz it's a woman
unless you thought Doc Brown was a woman
this whole time
no he does have nice hair it was just a
cohabit easy confusion Christian what
was the Spielberg movie that featured
the line if everything's ready here on
the Dark Side of the Moon play the five
tones the ho Bona versus Santa Christ if
I returned the rapping dog from the
enemy Titanic movie
I think I'm principal I have to give him
the points on that one the good Lord
really our fanfiction writer
the answer was Close Encounters of the
Third Kind with ponies Alex sing and it
actually says sing the rest of this line
from Ferris Bueller's Day Off when
Cameron was in Egypt's land
I hated that movie it's so helpful
really I don't know that scene you hated
Richard ropers favorite movie of all
time
it was awful it was just the worst thing
I might give you the point if you just
tell me what's the Matthew project what
was that what pushed over the edge just
to do here hey to Rodrick it was Cameron
the character is everyone and I just say
Matthew Broderick no it was let my
Cameron gooo Christensen which Dudley
Moore film had the exchange I'm going to
take a bath I'll alert the media dude -
dude - dude turn turn turn that is going
to be there if you do that again good
you like that show I think the pony
version will be better Alex in Back to
the Future which characters said why
don't you make like a tree and get out a
fifth Tannen yes
Christian in Dead Poets Society what
Latin phrase does Robin Williams say
which means seize the day
carpe diem yes or in Pony Alex finish
this line from When Harry Met Sally
you're the worst kind you're high
maintenance but you think you're not
you're so close low maintenance very
very close if Doc Brown said you
remember it Christian what Brandon Lee
film has a line let me tell you a little
something about murder it's fun it's
easy and you're gonna learn all about it
good rule Crowe you were close they both
have the word thaw in it Alex finish
this line from predator I ain't got time
to fuck around I don't remember the
predator you don't you don't remember
predator no I only saw it once
oh and you forgot it yes I am this close
to taking away those 10 points you have
my friend you should stick around I bet
you don't remember that do you because
they always said pretty dear ones what
was alien versus Predator the better
version to you is that and nursing that
you never said that it's alien versus
Predator you have to see it if you have
testicles it's the law watch police
version of it he has testicles okay it
was bleed which you will see a lot of
later Christian in patan which actor
said we're going to murder those lousy
hunt bastards by the bushel Jim Carrey
Jim Carrey's Patton
yeah he he gets out there from the
American flag bends over and says the
whole speech with his ass brilliant
brilliant
no it was short see Scott again easy
understand you to know your actors so
well it's a
amazing how just on target you are
knowing your actors Alex
finish this classic hopefully it's
classic to you line from commando Oh may
have UNC praetorium scene commando no I
haven't remember Sully when I promised
to kill you last I lied yes see that's
amazing that is how good this movie is
he hasn't even seen it and he knows that
damn wide yes
Christiane Conan the Barbarian claimed
three things were best in life crushing
your enemies seemed and driven before
you and hearing Pinkie Pie you know the
ponies aren't always gonna save you man
you're artists no I I know it's hard for
you to accept but they're just they're
not always gonna be there for you
friendship is not magic it's a series of
conditions that keeps a relationship
strong but not forever probably your
front I know and that's the saddest
thing about you Alex true or false
Harrison Ford say may the force be with
you in Star Wars Episode four a new home
I'm going to say false it is actually
true but that is a hard one to get well
that was our always enjoyable fantasy
attack it looks like Christian is the
one who avoided the spazzy attack which
means Alex you get to pay the penalty
and it is one of my choosing
you know it's December and it's getting
around Christmas really bless you with
Santa Claus so we're gonna get yes we're
gonna get you as Santa Claus / maybe
have predator Justin - a little bit
about great cinema and while we do that
Christian you get to watch this fancy
cartoon I need your help
not now son I'm on my way to a pony
convention
oh my god it's so funny really really
that's a kind man that's your cut you
let your own friendship is magic and
everything and you laughing at that have
you ever seen cupcakes I know of the
food oh you come here for a treat when
you see the video cupcakes is this all
your fan fictions about just watching
terrible things happen to cupcakes and
ponies kinda I'm gonna turn to the
normal one here that looks like Santa
Claus see it cries no just Santa Claus
oh that's your Santa laughs oh yeah
how'd it go again you're off by a whole
letter it's encourage him oh I'm gonna
get a whole out of you okay give me a ho
oh good
you get yourself a home later all right
let's go into round two round two and
we're gonna start with Christian
Christian in which movie - Kate Winslet
say meet me in Montauk - Jim Carrey the
masks even look like Kate Winslet who's
Kate Winslet I'm sure as a pony
fanfiction about her out there no it was
eternal sunshine of the spotless mind
Alex which Disney Villains said it's not
right for a woman to read soon as she
starts getting ideas and thinking what
is the guy's son
you sound like Hank Hill trying to do
Santa Claus unfortunately you're right
it was yes Christian which villain from
the Iron Man movies said you know who I
am you don't know where I am and you'll
never see me coming
the Mandarin yes Alex which Christopher
Nolan movie discusses the concept of
subconscious security inception yes
curtain
what was the spaghetti western that
contained the line in this world there's
two kinds of people my friend those with
loaded guns and those who dig you dig
boys ooh youkai a big panda don't care
come on you love that sword I've seen
you dancing to it my tag team I know you
love that song I might give you a point
if you do a pony rendition of it right
now
get on the points
I love making people dance for my
amusement Alex complete the line from
Bill and Ted's Excellent Adventure
be excellent to each other and be
radical a santa be radical oh no it was
party on dudes I haven't seen a movie
you're you're missing a treat my friend
is that one the one with that no that's
the second one how do you know the
second one everyone knows the first one
we have a Santa ever Christian of Star
Trek 4 or 5 or 6 which film heads Fox
say if I were human I believe my
response would be go to hell episode 5
the Empire Strikes Back
I'm really regretting not having you on
the Star Wars Episode no it was Star
Trek 6 the undiscovered country or tasty
undiscovered film Alex in Empire Strikes
Back
Luke told Yoda that he was not afraid
what was yours response be very afraid
I'm just imagining Yoda just like I'm
not afraid you are yeah give me the
point those Christian - which character
in Kill Bill did the bride say wiggle
your big toe ah that chick who dressed
up as Busse Lee you're strangely right
as its herself so yeah give them the
pokies Alex in Mary Poppins and Santa
you should know this movie well which
characters saying winds in the East mist
coming in like something is brewing
about to begin
Dick Van Dyke I'll give it to you it's
Burt it's the Santa suit not the voice
yeah Christian in the Simpsons what
Homer Simpson catchphrase was originally
described as an annoyed grunt don't yep
Alex in Monty Python the Holy Grail what
is Sir Lancelot favorite color blue
right
okay go Christian in Terminator 2
Judgment Day a character broke someone's
arm and said there's 215 bones in the
human body
that's one who was it Sarah Connor yes
Alex in Glengarry Glen Ross the first
prize for the month's sales contest was
a Cadillac Eldorado what was the second
prize you look like someone who's seen
Glengarry Glen Ross I have not a year
supply of months of what months a year
supply of months
yeah pocket what does that mean I know
you're Santa there's like time-traveling
stuff you just give out lunch is that
how you go around the world I thought
has a product name with munch the
products name was months mu n TS o
months yeah sure why not
what's the funny side what is wrong with
you two
got bad hearing it was a set of steak
knives thank Jesus that's the end of the
round it looks like by god I'm amazed
you have this many Alex has 70 and
Christian you have a hundred with sadly
I've never had to kill Santa Claus
before and I'm definitely not doing that
here because you are nothing like Santa
Claus oh this is pretty easy
off you go Alex yes die die die yes off
you go come on wait wait let me hear one
more Santa laughs Oh Christian you are
making it to the final round which we
will continue with after if you like to
be a contestant a pop quiz hotshot and
live in the Chicagoland area send a
video via YouTube stating your name ate
and why you the figure with the other
contestant
[Music]
welcome back to pop quiz saw Chuck
Christian congratulations you'll be
badly against a nostalgia critic in our
final round I'll be reading seven
questions Christian if you defeats a
critic you'll win that the exploded
remains of Donald job no seriously we'll
do it some of these guys shut this guy
up
also $100 in cash and of course you're
alive damn Skippy all right I'll be
reading a series of movie soundtrack
raps you will need to identify the movie
critic are you ready for this never but
let's do it anyway Christian are you
ready I love rap music let's begin
Christian been spending most our lives
living in the gangsta's paradise poison
hood incorrect critic mini-me you
complete me Austin Powers inspires egg
correct Christian you better lose
yourself in the music the moment you own
it incorrect critic the good guy is
dressed in black remember that man in
black correct
Christian half-shell they're heroes for
in this day and age who can ask for more
Michael Bay's Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles incorrect it was the original
Deena Street Ninja Turtles critic James
West came into West so remember to the
name while OS correct Christian come on
come on the black suits covered and
black to correct critic go ninja go
ninja go ninja turtles - correct
Christian they do what they want to do
say what they want to say live how they
want to live playing how they want to
play it's a movie incorrect
critic they'd be dust enough ghosts let
you ghosts dusters ghostbusters -
correct
Christian if I hit up high hit him high
hit him high and if you hit him low hit
him low hit him low it says they're
incorrect critic only a friend alone can
understand my pain if only I could get
some message from a Great Dane
scooby-dooby-doo correct
Christian well there it is the Addams
Family incorrect that was Addams Family
Values and finally critic you know it
ain't no stoppin all the dogs on
dropping
it's Friday night so everything is
poppin
all dogs go to heaven incorrect and the
winner is so sorry it looks like the
next fanfiction that's gonna be written
is about your funeral don't worry we'll
have you as a pony it'll feel good Oh
what do you got on let's see you're 35
you got a bike for me
yeah microphone I have no cash my bank
card
I think you are dead my friend go go
taken fuck that guy for the car do you
know like I've never heard that before
every time I go to a con it sounds like
a bad credit card back I never hear
before you know you know you know I just
never ever hear it at all it's like the
last thing I overhear and then you know
what else he did the Doug team suck
never hear that why go to a convention
either I'm just like oh what's that I'm
not familiar with that at all but no no
I hear all the time all the time man you
know you know you know y'all crazy
doesn't it right yeah just maybe Signet
come with me next time get let me browse
no no no why not
because it goes to bad credit
[Music]
you